in a purported breakdown of the first
two-thirds of the rise of Skywalker's
plots reddit user Jedi Pacus has claimed
that something major goes on at the end
of the movie second act specifically
somewhat Star Wars fan said goodbye to
just a few years ago will supposedly
make an epic unexpected return a rumored
crucial part to the rise of Skywalker
could involve the inner turmoil of atom
drivers kylo Ren the former ven Solo has
spent his adult life striving to emulate
Darth Vader by rising through the ranks
of the first-order and pledging
allegiance to the Empire his path has
been pretty dark throughout the force
awakens and the last Jedi but some fans
have theorized that the new supreme
leader could be redeemed in the rise of
Skywalker how might that happened today
according to some fans none other than
Kyle Lohse father han Solo played by
Harrison Ford will return in the rise of
Skywalker and offer his son a chance at
redemption the moment allegedly happens
after kylo and Rey engage in a tense
lightsaber battle during which both
force-sensitive fighters can feel that
Leia is dying
this heightens their emotions and pushes
ready to grab kylos weapon and drive it
through his chest
she tells kylo that she will never be
like him before summoning her newfound
healing ability to save kylo from death
afterwards
Rey steals kylo ship and Darth Vader's
wayfinder device to head to Endor leavin
kylo broken and defeated it's here where
Han Solo reportedly appears to kylo is a
vision and tells him that it's never too
late to return to the light and make the
right choice
kylo is said to be moved by the
conversation with his late father and
decides to become Ben solo again thus
returning to the light side the idea of
kylo Ren stripping away is dark persona
reclaiming his birth name offense solo
and turning to the light side is an
intriguing thought but will it actually
happen in the rise of Skywalker
similarly will Harrison Ford actually
circle back to the Star Wars franchise
to play the character whose son killed
him in cold blood
neither are out of the realm of
possibility given that some pretty wild
stuff has gone on in the Star Wars
universe before as fans have heard at
least a hundred times since the news of
episode 9 first broke the movie will
bring the Star Wars saga to a definitive
end for this final film showcase the
last fight between the first-order and
the resistance as well as a redemption
for Kyle
Ren SAR wars has brought dead characters
back as force ghosts and visions before
so it's not unreasonable to think that
Han would resurface as a vision to his
son offering him guidance at the lowest
point in his life still kylo did
straight-up kill Han in the force
awakens so there's something to be said
about whether Han is the person kylo
needs strength from another thing worth
considering when pondering the
possibility of Han Solo returning in the
rise of Skywalker is whether Harrison
Ford would want to be a part of the film
as Ford told Jimmy Kimmel he's been
pushing for solos to die for almost 30
years so that may mean that he considers
the death the ultimate culmination of
the character no I argued for 30 years
for this to happen right and finally I
wore him down
still there's really no better way to
bring it back to the franchise than by
helping redeem his wayward son there's
also the chance that this alleged plot
breakdown holds no weight and what
actually happens in the rise of
Skywalker isn't even remotely close to
what's rumored kylo could stay on the
dark side han Solo could stay off-screen
and a completely different sequence of
events could unravel fans will simply
have to wait to learn the truth when the
rise of Skywalker arrives in theaters on
December 20th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]